really the top story this morning the
the true melting of the ice between the
NFL franchises in Colin Kaepernick
because after three plus years of
Kaepernick being shunned Chris now
they're talking openly about Colin
Kaepernick Anthony Linden the Chargers
coach spoke with the media on Wednesday
and was asked about Colin Kaepernick
here is what Lynn had to say cap was a
he was a starting quarterback a suitable
quarterback in this league I think it
would be crazy to not have it might work
out list Colin definitely fixed the
style of quarterback for the system that
we're going to be running and I'm very
confident and happy within three
quarterbacks that I have but uh you know
you can never have too many people
waiting on the runway and look the gist
of it from Anthony Lynn was that Colin
Kaepernick is on the list now he's on
the workout list and it's obvious that
over the last three years that list that
every team maintains of quarterbacks to
call in the event that a guy gets
injured or that a guy just isn't any
good that list did not include Colin
Kaepernick because he wasn't getting the
calls other than a visit to the Seahawks
in 2017 I'll work out with the Seahawks
that was eventually aborted in 2018 that
was it that was all that Kaepernick got
so he wasn't on the list well now he is
now that the Commissioner has come out
on multiple occasions specifically one
occasion this weakens that I encourage
teams to sign Colin Kaepernick he's
popping up on these lists Chris I mean
on one hand better late than never on
the other hand it kind of proves in a
roundabout way that he has been
blackballed yes it does you know I think
what Roger Goodell did you know the
statements he made the other you know
last weekend or last week whatever it
was about Colin Kaepernick and those
issues and everything like that I do
think it started people having the
conversation more and as probably
encourage teams to have the conversation
to you know I thought Anthony Lynn like
he was I think send announced and you
know silent signals there right I mean
he was kind of basically saying like of
Cour
she's good enough to play in the NFL I
feel like he was almost putting a little
pressure on his own team like hey we'll
welcome him here we can never have
enough good quarterbacks on the roster
certainly so I think this would the
NFL's take and of course where we are in
America right now III think this
conversation is going to you know
embolden a lot of front office people
coaches maybe people that were scared of
this situation and Colin Kaepernick and
everything that goes along with it now I
think there's gonna be more acceptance
and conversation and I think ultimately
that will lead to Colin Kaepernick on a
football team and back in the NFL we'll
see if that's the case or whether or not
people are just paying lip-service the
reality is we had never heard things
like this before and a half man come out
and make it clear and look let's look at
the charges because I think a fit is
there I think that if Colin Kaepernick
attire Rod Taylor had a chance to
compete head-to-head for the starting
job with the loser being the backup and
Justin Herbert having a scholarship year
to kind of watch and learn in 2020 I
would Kapernick have a chance to beat
out Tyrod Taylor I mean Kaepernick at
his best is better than Taylor at his
best the question is how long does it
take capper to keep to get back to the
point where he and even if he can get
back to the bass as good as he ever was
that's really the issue that would have
to be resolved in a month of training
camp yeah that's it Mike you're right I
mean like the first part of your
question I think at a base level how you
know it anybody that's got eyes and
watching football you know over the last
decade yeah Colin Kaepernick at his best
certainly better than Tyrod Taylor and
that's no disrespect to Tyrod Taylor I
know he's a good player and does a lot
of things Kaepernick special you know
Kaepernick was running for 70 and 80
yard runs on the legion of boom when
nobody could get four yard runs on the
legion of boom and he was throwing the
lasers around the field against the
legion of boom when when everybody was
struggling to do anything so he was a
special special talent did it fall off a
little bit there yeah of course it did
why Mike because it's a team sport and
he was coached by some people that were
not deserving of being a head coach and
the team fell apart but he was still
every bit as worthy of being a starting
quarterback at that point so you know
I don't know if he can compete with him
right away but he could definitely
justify a roster spot and doing that
Mike no doubt and and I want to share
something specific about the fun a few
years of Colin Kaepernick's career in
San Francisco that that's better off in
a few minutes when we play sound from
someone else for now for the Chargers he
fits and here's the other side of it too
okay they're competing with the Rams in
LA and they're losing I know you had you
had Colin Kaepernick and all of a sudden
Colin Kaepernick's Jersey becomes the
hottest selling jersey in all of
football in all of sports and the
Chargers become the more attractive team
in LA and beyond they would leave the
Rams in the dust if they signed Colin
Kaepernick and said it's Kaepernick and
tail are competing and training camp to
see who the starter is now it requires a
coach with the kind of quiet strength
that Anthony Lin possesses to be able to
say tie rods the better guy because
there will be people openly rooting for
Kaepernick to be the starter and Anthony
Lin's gonna have to decide who the
better guy is if it comes down to it it
looks like it's not it looks like if
Tyrod Taylor gets injured Kaepernick's
gonna get the call but the point is
there are real reasons here for the
Chargers to pursue this and if he was
just introducing the message into the
organization by putting some pressure on
them by talking about it publicly Tom
telesco the GM and the Spanos family
should really take a step back and say
from a business standpoint mm-hmm this
could be very interesting for us from a
fund development standpoint and and
again who wants to be the modern-day
branch rickey Anthony Lee and Tom
telesco Spanos family crammed together
would get that recognition for being the
ones to finally do the right thing after
three and a half years ya know I think
I'm with you I mean I hear you you make
all the right points Mike I thought
about you as soon as I heard Anthony
Lind make these comments first off he's
kind of you know first one to address
the situation pretty much say he
deserves to be in the NFL put a little
pressure on his own team to say hey you
know we could handle them he fits our
system that's great Mike I only see one
thing that we could question as a
negative with Kaepernick and the
Chargers and that's the fact that they
drafted over
a quarterback in number six right and
maybe they just don't want to have
another cook in the kitchen to take away
attention from him and compete against
him and who knows maybe ultimately
Kaepernick comes back and does look as
good as he looks for year three four
years ago and then you go oh man you
know we got a guy here that's kind of
threatening to our six six pick of the
draft so that would be the only thing I
don't think that's a big thing
especially with like you said I think
there's a good chance Herbert gets red
shirted we'll see how that goes but I
think it's certainly something an
organization and coaches would have to
talk about before they brought him in if
you have a top ten pick quarterback that
you just took they've been down this
road before though when they got Phillip
Rivers as the fourth overall pick
remembering was the first overall pick
by the Chargers they traded him for
Rivers who was picked fourth by the
Giants he sat behind Drew Brees for two
seasons two full seasons behind Brees
and they eventually let briefs leave via
free agency the problem is if Kaepernick
ends up now this falls into the good
problem to have category I assume if
Kaepernick ends up being really good for
the Chargers then how long do you keep
Justin Herbert on the bench because
ideally by 2021 2022 at the latest
Herbert's the guy but but but still
again it would be a good problem to have
to have Kaepernick come in and play so
well that you're thinking oh my god what
are we gonna do with Justin Herbert but
it sounds like that move is many moves
down the road for the Chargers the
bigger thing is somebody finally coming
out and saying yes he's on our list for
potential workouts and we'll see if they
have to put their money where their
mouth is at some point in the future now
Marc Davis the owner of the Las Vegas
Raiders chiming in here's a quote that
he gave to Paul Gutierrez of ESPN since
2017 I've told the coaches and general
managers that if they want to hire Colin
Kaepernick they have my blessing
well two things first of all it would
have been nice for him to say that
publicly in 2017 at a time when it was
clear that Colin Kaepernick was being
collectively shunned by the NFL
I mean we're gonna start having people
come out of the woodwork now said hey
I've been fine with this all along okay
you should have said so three years ago
downtown Brady exactly bill yeah
secondly and others and others not
Belichick secondly like if Mark Davis
I've always told them if they want to
hire Colin Kaepernick they're my
blessing like you know a way if you
really want to do that go ahead I mean
it's up to you like sometimes the way
it's communicated you send the message
of what you really want hey you know
it's hates your job you know if you want
an iron go ahead I mean Ito so I don't
put a lot of stock in that on the
surface especially when there have been
ample opportunities for Mark Davis over
the last three years to stand up and say
hey what's going on here in the NFL why
aren't people hiring this guy I've told
my people go ahead and hire him so and I
know Mark Davis needs to to toe the
party line to a certain extent but also
the owner of the Raiders historically
whether it's Mark Davis or Al Davis has
not been all that concerned about saying
the things that the league office would
want him to say so I just I just I just
wonder where was this at any point
before yesterday well I know I think
that's but I think this is like positive
signs in some way you're right and then
you notice I don't doubt Mark Davis he's
probably has said that to his coaches
and everybody else I don't but you're
right you'd like to have seen that
support at a time where you know back in
time it was more relevant or it's more
supportive but I think the positives we
could take out of this Mike again is
here we got two prominent people in the
NFL on the same day you know on the same
day the president questioned Kaepernick
and things like that who kind of came an
endorsement and I think that says
something to where we are as a society
and certainly where we are in the NFL
that we're not going to be like you know
the terror deterred from anything here
as far as the main goal the main mission
supporting our players and they're not
going to be scared off this pedestal of
talking about Colin Kaepernick because
it makes a certain part of America
uncomfortable and I do like that aspect
of it nonetheless there's a sense that
they're chipping away and chipping away
right hipping away at this and but but
the question is do they keep chipping
until the dam break
I know I'm mixing metaphors but do they
keep chipping or or do they just stop
and say okay that's enough P people are
satisfied that we're saying the right
things about Colin Kapernick I don't
think that that's gonna be enough I
think it's needing this momentum where
if Kaepernick doesn't end up on a team
it's all going to feel very incomplete
the president yesterday answering
questions from Sinclair reporter Scott
Shuman had this to say about Colin
Kaepernick it's kind of a compliment and
kind of an insult wrapped into one here
it is when it comes to sports and
kneeling do you think Colin Kaepernick
should get another shot in the NFL if he
deserves that he should if he has the
playing ability he was he started off
great and then he didn't end up very
great in terms of as a player he he was
terrific in his rookie year I think he
was very good in his second year and
then something happened so his playing
wasn't up to snuff the answer is
absolutely I would
as far as kneeling I would love to see
him get another shot but obviously he
has to be able to play well if he can't
play well I think it would be very
unfair okay so I don't have any problem
with him playing but he's no good that's
why he's not playing and and and look
that's kind of almost word-for-word
identical to what the president said
back in August when he was asked about
Colin Kaepernick now it wasn't as big of
an issue then as it is now but the idea
is yeah I don't have any problem of the
team signing me just isn't any good and
and and and let's be clear about his
career as a starter first of all we
didn't play as a rookie it was 2012 when
he came in after Alex Smith suffered a
concussion he played well enough to keep
Smith on the bench he ended up being the
start of the rest of the year they
almost won the Super Bowl 2013 he was
very good good enough to get a major
contract extension in 2014 and that's
when the problems started for him as a
starter the last year of Jim Harbaugh
and all the dysfunction between him and
Trent Baalke that contributed to the
team being not very good that
contributed to Kaepernick having a bit
of a regression the next year Jim
Tomsula as the head coach something that
all due respect Jim never should have
had
and that contributed to further
regression and then 2016 chip Kali who
never should have been the head coach
that's when it all bought him doubt and
that's when colin kaepernick in 2016 he
said oh he got benched for Blaine
Gabbert he wasn't healthy at the start
of the season he right into the Year
offseason
needing three different surgeries Chris
three different surgeries they tried to
trade him to the Broncos because he
didn't fit with what Chip Kelly was
doing he wasn't healthy
they couldn't trade him he had fully
guaranteed money as of April one that
they couldn't get away from because of
the surgeries and he couldn't pass a
physical before April 1 and then when he
finally did play they they weren't good
enough to win football games and yes he
was declining as a starter that doesn't
mean he should have been flushed out of
the league altogether
Mitchell true Biscay has declined as a
starter that doesn't mean he gets
flushed out of the league after 2020 if
nick foles becomes the guy with the
bears true Biscay goes somewhere else as
a back up just like Jameis Winston just
like Marcus Mariota you don't get
flushed out of the league just because
the window has closed on you as a
starter because number one the window
could open again and number two you're
still good enough to be number two on
someone else's team because there aren't
64 good quarterbacks to go around so I
don't get we I don't understand how the
people who don't want to see Colin
Kaepernick employed just gloss over the
fact that if he was regressing as a
starter he deserves to not work in the
NFL at all yeah that's just it's BS
talking points Mike I mean that's all
that is I mean we shouldn't even pay
attention to that you said he wasn't you
said he wasn't good enough to be a
starter four years ago well he wasn't
that doesn't mean he should be ejected
from the NFL he should go somewhere to
be a backup well Mike and it goes back
to my you know age-old adage where I
always talk about like hey you know I
don't care who you are we could have put
a lot of quarterbacks on that team in
San Francisco under Mike Tomsula and
Chip Kelly at that time and they would
have looked a lot worse than they are in
reality you know you got to have a
system teammates around you to support
you
coaching staff that's you know able to
adjust to the NFL and things like that
I mean Chip Kelly we're seeing I mean he
didn't exactly go back to college
football and start tearing it up again
you know so the NFL had caught on to
that offense so India for people to
argue that they're truly just haters
they're trying to change the subject or
don't want to deal the subject or
whatever it may be
colin kaepernick yes you know 2016 was
he at his best
no was he still in my opinion one of the
best 32 quarterbacks in football yes he
was he has a special skill set very
special I mean the fact that he can run
around run away from DBS and safeties
and he has an unbelievably powerful arm
throwing the football those are two
assets that are you know huge and making
quarterbacks successful you don't always
have to have that but that was part of
what made him successful and for anybody
else to argue anything else is just it's
insane so you know again like I said we
could have put a lot of good
quarterbacks on those teams right there
and we would have got her they're still
starting quarterback caliber and I would
have said yes they are they've just got
a lot of crap around them and when
you've got a lot of crap around you
sometimes you start to smell and look
like crap - lovely enjoy your breakfast
or you're in the UK
here's the thing 2016 he still started
11 games once he was healthy they
benched Blaine Gabbert and he started 11
games they were 1 in 10 in the games he
started which is horrendous he still had
16 touchdown passes and four
interceptions which under the
circumstances is stunning these
conversations with radio people on my
podcast whatever it may be you know yeah
one in ten okay I get it nobody expected
though any of those games like the 49ers
are supposed to win them or do anything
special and yeah at the very least he
showed you okay even though he might
have not been playing his best and
certainly the team wasn't his best he
could take care of the football and he
was still capable of making plays that a
lot of other quarterbacks in the game
couldn't so yeah you know I listen
there's no argument as far as that's
concerned there's only one reason he
hasn't been in the NFL we know what that
is okay and hopefully now we're seeing
the tide turning and the NFL is being
more accepting of it they're not bowing
down to the political pressure the
president anything like that and I am
hopefull I think the NFL is smart enough
this time around and know and what
you've been banging on the table for
Mike the guy needs to be on a team and
then all this talk and huffing and
puffing we've been doing is for nothing
if it doesn't get Colin Kaepernick back
in the league and kind of set the record
straight and I think that would go over
big with this society and of course the
players in the league and Chris the
political pressure is going nowhere the
president was on Sean Hannity show last
night on Fox News and reiterated once
again his mandate that thou shalt stand
for the national anthem and targeted
Drew Brees I don't know why he caved I
don't know why he retracted his
beautiful statement that he made a few
weeks ago one day later and then went
after the Commissioner too and made the
comment I don't know why he put that
video statement out nobody was asking
for it which the players were demanding
it it was a reaction to a very
compelling video that apparently the
president the only person in the country
they didn't see that video so it was
kind of strange to take that shot at
Goodell but the point is that button
that very easy button you know it's like
press a button and get a piece of candy
he's gonna keep pressing that button and
getting pieces of candy from now until
the election because he sees no downside
to saying you must stand for the anthem
because when he says that his base is
going to say hell yeah you must stand
for the anthem so the thing is the NFL
no longer seems to be hiding under its
bed when that issue comes up not that
they're going to engage him in an
all-out fight I just think they're going
to ignore him yeah the best way to show
that they're willing to ignore him is to
say hey Colin Kaepernick's back in the
NFL and you know what plenty of players
are going to be Neal
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports